[Music]
boosting the recovery as EU countries
gradually begin relaxing lockdown
measures the economy needs a kickstart
Parliament backed a 750 billion euro
recovery plan with the EU Green Deal at
its core on top of this MEP is one to
the next seven-year budget to build on
the economic recovery and get Europe
back on its feet investing in health the
coronavirus crisis has tested the
resilience of our health care
infrastructure EU for health is a nine
point four billion euro program which
will increase a preparedness in the face
of cross-border health threats and
bolster our health care systems
protecting businesses lock downs and
border closures have left many small and
medium businesses struggling through the
European Investment Fund more than 1
billion euros has been made available
incentivizing banks to provide loans to
100,000 European businesses supporting
the unemployed for those who find
themselves out of work the shore
initiative is providing up to 100
billion euros in loans to member states
to cover the cost of short time work and
furlough schemes help for tourism the EU
is coordinating the gradual reopening of
European tourism and promoting Europe as
a safe travel destination Member States
can now introduce voucher and loans aims
to support tourism jobs and businesses
banking requirements
following the 2008 financial crash
wolves were put in place by the EU to
help banks weather crises the relaxation
of the capital requirements regulation
will now give banks the flexibility they
need allowing them to lend and absorb
losses due to the pandemic help for
farmers and fisheries the --use
agricultural and Fisheries sectors have
continued to provide us with safe and
healthy food despite major challenges
during lockdown individual farmers are
now eligible to up to 7,000 euros in
compensation while small agri-food
businesses can receive up to 50,000
euros in help the EU has also
implemented aid for food storage and
more flexibility in market support
programs helping EU countries worth some
37 billion euros the coronavirus
response investments initiative is
helping Member States fund their Kovach
19 Crisis Response maximum flexibility
ensures that national governments can
invest the funds where they are needed
for most state aid rules the EU has
relaxed the rules on how EU governments
can support people and companies the
temporary framework allows for up to
eight hundred thousand euros of grants
per company low-cost or guaranteed loans
and help for export businesses
protecting European assets in times of
crisis some businesses can be vulnerable
to foreign takeovers and state
subsidized competitors the EU has called
on member states to screen bids which
could risk the EU's security or public
order and to ensure fair competition
rules apply to everyone
[Music]